so there have been a lot of Avengers for
leaks lately and as exciting as they are
none of them actually come from anything
official from Marvel that is until now
we have our first official Avengers for
synopsis from Marvel themselves just a
quick reminder about the giveaway I'm
giving away copies of infinity war and
ant-man and the wasp on blu-ray as well
as some special edition posters if you
would like to enter for your chance to
win all you have to do is subscribe to
my channel like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero so just like Marvel
did with Avengers infinity war and other
Marvel movies they have come out with an
artbook for the movie called the road to
Avengers 4 you can find this on presale
on amazon.com and with this comes the
official synopsis for Avengers 4 again
this is straight from Marvel so we know
that it's 100% legit the synopsis reads
as follows the fourth installment in the
avengers saga will be the culmination of
22 interconnected films and we'll let
audiences witness the turning point of
this epic journey this collectible
volume features art from films leading
up to this terylene event including
additional behind-the-scenes art
interviews and photography from Avengers
infinity war so there are a few things
to talk about with this synopsis but one
of the major things is that this
synopsis was actually released this past
May right as Avengers infinity war came
out
now obviously infinity war had all the
hype as it just came out in theaters and
this did not come from an official
source at the time but now that the road
to Avengers 4 came out and the synopsis
for it is exactly the same almost it
legitimizes this past synopsis leaked
the two differ just a tiny bit so here's
what the one in May had to say a
culmination of 22 interconnected films
the fourth installment of the Avenger
saga will draw audiences to witness the
turning point of this epic journey my
beloved heroes will truly understand how
fragile this reality is and the
sacrifices that must be made to uphold
it okay so the major things that stick
out to me in these are turning point
fragile reality and sacrifices when I
hear Turning Point I obviously think of
deaths we know that Avengers 4 is going
to be wrapping up the story arc of these
22 films we're wrapping up the stories
from the first 10 years and although
some characters will be sticking around
for face for getting new stories we know
that some characters such as Iron Man
and Captain America are coming to an end
whether that's by death or by retirement
and passing the mantle down the Captain
America and Iron Man we know are coming
to an end and that's obviously a huge
turning point because they're the leader
of the Avengers so moving forward after
Avengers 4 there will be new leaders and
new characters but another thing that
comes to mind when I hear Turning Point
that also kind of falls into the reality
side is the cosmic future of the MCU so
when I think about the cosmic future of
the MCU and I hear turning-point and
fragile realities I think about the
Celestials showing up and not just the
Celestials but the cosmic entities as
well who better to show the Avengers how
fragile their reality is than the ones
who can control reality and then of
course I think about the quantum realm
time travel and multiple realities a
plot leak that came out months ago said
that the Avengers will have to travel to
different realities and go throughout
time to collect the Infinity stones
obviously going to different realities
and going forward and backwards in time
would show them just in fact how fragile
their reality is and then you get into
the sacrifices again obviously
sacrifices takes me back to deaths now
there's no real way of knowing who's
going to die in Avengers 4 but I do
think that there will be some deaths and
when I hear sacrifices I think about the
soulstone we know that in order to
obtain the soul stone one must sacrifice
one that they love now obviously there
are just so many different scenarios
that could play out here but I think the
one that everybody thinks about is
Captain America sacrificing himself so
Ironman can obtain the soul stone
obviously this is just speculation and
theorizing we have no way of knowing
what's really going to happen but this
is what I think about when I hear
sacrifices that and I picture Captain
America lifting up Thor's hammer yelling
Avengers Assemble as he goes and takes
on Thanos
I think if any of the Avengers are going
to sacrifice themselves to save another
Avenger or the rest of the Avengers it's
definitely going to be Captain America
so although we don't know for sure what
is going to happen in Avengers for right
now we definitely know that it's going
to be a super intense movie and it will
be a turning point in the MCU so that's
it for the synopsis breakdown let me
know what you all think about this
synopsis let me know what you all think
about the turning point fragile reality
and sacrifices in the comments below
don't forget to subscribe comment and
like the video so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date with
everything relating to Avengers 4 as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]
you